c'était le procès que tout le monde
attendait depuis des mois voir des
années après les rumeurs les soupçons
les questions on allait passer au faits
dans cette affaire qui agitait le
microcosme touronjo il y avait de
l'argent de la politique et même de
l'amour et du sexe selon certains mais
il n'y avait pas encore de drame il est
arrivé comme ça dans cette matinée du 7
avril alors qu'on ne l'attendait pas
décation c'est jean-germain qu'on
attendait patiemment pour commencer puis
avec étonnement puis avec
inquiétude je vous en prie je suis
bouleversé parce que je crois que
jean-germain avait fait l'objet
d'accusation
infâme j'ai évoqué Roger salingro auprès
de certains d'entre
vous ce matin il a disparu en laissant
une lettre d'adieu à son
domicile j'espère qu'on va le retrouver
vivant en l'absence du prévenu le plus
important les micros se tournent vers
l'autre personnage essentiel du procès
Lisane qui avait préparé ses
explications pour le tribunal et qui
s'explique finalement devant la
presse je suis naffra cette situation
mais je pense pas je suis
cisée parce que tout ce que je fais
c'est exposer la vérité si voulais moi
je après c'est vrai chacun il y a sa
nature voyez moi je
j'ai jamais eu problème de reconnaî si
je fait une
bêtise
voilà l'attente dure une heure puis la
nouvelle est confirmée le corps de
jean-germain a été retrouvé dans son
garage il a pris le soin de faire
parvenir une lettre à son avocat au
palais de justice pour expliquer son
gesteermain est
mort c'est un martyre de la République
dans cette affaire il a été jeté au
chien et comme il l'a écrit dans la
lettre qu'il a laissé derrière lui leur
conscience les
poursuivra je voudrais simplement vous
lire un extrait de la lettre qu'on a
retrouvé on ne peut laisser la chasse
systématique au politique se dérouler
normalement quotidiennement il est des
êtres j'en suis pour lesquels
l'injustice et le déshonneur sont
insupportables la presse le parquet vous
êtes aujourd'hui les responsables de la
mort de
jean-germain 7 ans plus tôt la presse
était plutôt la bienvenue dans le grand
salon d'honneur de la ville de tour tout
près du tribunal quand les mariages
chinois étaient une affaire qui marche
et pas encore une affaire tout
court au mois d'octobre j'en ai 100 qui
viennent
d'un petit peu partout de Pékin de
shangï on fait tout pour ce qu'ils
aiment pour qu'ils aiment la
Touren proposer à des couples chinois
déjà mariés une cérémonie symbolique et
romantique à la française pour qu'ils
viennent dépenser leurs devises dans les
magasins et les hôtels de Touren c'est
une idée qu'avait eu jean-germain
lui-même une idée saluée à l'époque par
ses adversaires politiques heureux de
constater que grâce au mariage la ville
de tour était l'une des attration de
l'Exposition universelle de
shanghï c'était phénoménal quand vous
visitez le le pavillon le pavillon
français quand vous arriviez en bas vous
aviez une queue qui remontait il y avait
je sais pas c'était le pavillon le plus
visité le pavillon de la Touren et donc
oui on avait une fierté de de voir que
pour nous c une belle
opération pour organiser l'opération
jeangmain recr auin de son cabinet LAN
originaire de Taiwan installé en France
depuis 20 ans elle est dans un premier
temps un rouage essentiel de la réussite
du projet mais elle va provoquer son
échec en raison d'un mélange des genres
interdit par le code des marchés publics
alors qu'elle est salarié de la mairie
la société qu'elle a créé et dont elle
est restée actionnaire bénéficie de
l'intégralité des appels d'offres émis
par la ville et l'agglomération dans les
affaires chinoises pour un total
supérieur à 800000 € c'est vrai que
c'est ça c'est une erreur enfin que
uneattention de ma part je suis toujours
resté associée de cette société jusqu'au
jusqu'au là on est 2011 je CIS début
l'année 2011 et pendant tout ces tempsl
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment
uneattention je dis voilà il faut je
reconnaiss C d' erreur hein je suis
vraiment très très nafraé causer tous
ces ennuis à Monsieur le Maire il est
absolument pour faireous évidemment on
le savait pas hein sinon je vois pas
comment le service des marchés de la
ville de tour m'aurait proposé de de
signer ce genre de chose mais je pense
que ça a été corrigé donc je pense
qu'elle a commis une erreur mais qui a
été corrigé assez assez rapidement et il
y a pas de de de de de détournement de
fond de de de choses comme ça c'est un
article du Canard Enchaîné qui révèle
sur la place publique l'ampleur de
l'erreur sa parution déclenche une
procédure judiciaire où l'on découvre de
nombreuses irrégularités dans les
comptes de la société de Lisane qui vont
au-delà de la simple tourderie dans le
meilleur des cas on peut penser à de la
négligence mais aux yeux des juges cela
relève de
l'escroquerie à partir de là la
solidarité n'est plus à l'ordre du jour
entre le maire et sa collaboratrice qui
doit quitter la mairie avant d'être
licencié de l'office du tourisme où on
l'avait
recasé je m'interroge sur la situation
d'une de vos anciennes salariées qui a
été l'une de vos proches collaboratrice
dans le casadre d'une certaine
manifestation ancienne collaboratrice
qui aujourd'hui vousut traduit au prudom
et qui de sur quoi vous réclame 150000 €
de dommage et intérêt j'y vois là encore
la suite logique et inéluctable d'une
gestion non transparente de ce dossier
que je dénonce depuis maintenant 3 ans
je sais que vous avez toujours beaucoup
d'idées en ce qui concerne la Chine on
n'a pas eu de chance avec un certain
nombre de sujet mais c'éit un beau
projet il le demeure et j'espère si je
suis réélu avec mon équipe pouvoir
recommencer dans quelques
années battu au municipal jean-germain
n'aura pas l'occasion de recommencer
après le rendez-vous électoral raté ces
rendez-vous avec les juges n'ont pas été
plus heureux ils ne l'ont pas soupçonné
d'avoir détourné de l'argent à des fins
personnelles mais ils ont considéré
qu'il ne pouvaient pas ignorer la façon
dont sa collaboratrice menait ses
affaires et l'ont renvoyait devant le
tribunal correctionnel pour complicité
de prise illégale d'intérêt dans le
respect bien sûr de la confidentialité
le calendrier
judiciaire est si calqué sur le
calendrier politique on a beaucoup de
mal à croire au hasard
euh dans un ciel sans nuage arrive cette
campagne de presse en pleines élections
sénatoriales jean-germain aurait pu être
mise en examen le lendemain par aucun
nouvel élément qui soit intervenu on
attend 2 ans et en pleine campagne des
municipales ça refait la une des
journaux parce qu'il est mis en
examen voilà donc jean-gmain était
absolument convaincu qu'il avait une
orchestration de tout ça maintenant je
suis pas capable de vous la démontrer
aujourd'hui ce sentiment de persécution
va être forcé à quelques jours de
l'audience lorsque jean-germain apprend
à l'avance contrairement aux règles de
procédure pénale le contenu des
réquisitions qui prévoit à son encontre
de la prison
ferme j'en ai été informé mercredi
dernier par l'avocat d'une partie civile
et à l'arrivée à l'audience le procureur
me l'a confirmé mais j'en avais informé
jean-germain desè mercredi dernier le
fait que le procureur annonce des
réquisitions d'emprisonnement ferme
c'est c'était délirant par rapport à ce
dossier vous chercherez dans l'histoire
de France on n jamais vu de réquisition
d'emprisonnement ferme pour un maire qui
n'a jamais été condamné et lorsqu'il n'y
a pas d'enrichissement personnel donc
qu'il ait eu le sentiment d'une sorte
d'hallaliie organisé par tous ceux qui
travaillaient à sa mise à mort politique
certainement si un délit a été commis
dans l'affaire des mariages chinois
valit-il de la prison ferme et valit-il
la mort d'un homme jean-germain a
répondu à sa manière à ces questions
mais lors du procès qui se déroulera
finalement en octobre ses réponses
manqueront pour éclairer les nombreuses
zones d'ombrees qui entour encore le
dossier dans la période d'émotion qui a
suivi sa mort de nombreux touronau ont
eux déjà jugé l'homme rassemblé pour lui
rendre hommage ils ont estimé que les
affaires ne devaient pas occulter ce
qu'il avait fait pour la
ville avec tout ce qui s'est passé les
gens il parlai beaucoup donc sur les
réseaux sociaux j'ai vu des commentaires
vraiment qui m'a fait mal au cœur donc
je voulais vraiment qu' qu'il sache d'où
il est qu' voit que en fait il était pas
tout seul qu'il était enfin voilà qu'il
y avait du monde ça me rappelle un peu
l'histoire enfin quand j'ai appris la
nouvelle de berryovois il y a un
parallèle dans le dans le retentissement
de des choses et voilà je suis venue ici
spontanément
la ville de tour a aussi rendu un
hommage officiel à son ancien mare élu
de droite et de gauche ils étaient tous
rassemblés dans le grand salon d'honneur
parmi eux se trouvait aussi ce que
jean-germain avait désigné à tort ou à
raison comme les responsables de sa
mort